has agreed to put the headset on from
Salt Lake City and Jo this now and you
have 50 stop looking at the stat sheet
tyres Tyrese I don't I don't know how a
day gets any better than being named to
your first All-Star team and then going
for a career-high 51 put this put this
day and night in a nutshell for me ah
man this it's been a great night I mean
it's been wonderful um it's funny I'm
trying to watch the the selection or
whatever and uh I can't even my mom and
Joel they keep FaceTiming me I can't
even watched the selection I don't even
know if they said my name or not but um
it's been great man we fought you know
we had a hard Trip Man IA had injuries
Joel had injuries uh a lot of guys was
out but we was able to finish it off
with window up Ty sha here I played with
great players such as Kobe Bryant rest
in peace a dwade and they would tell me
at times hey I'm getting 509 with the
absence of Joel did you say to yourself
I need to get 50 tonight for us to get a
win yeah honestly you know when I found
out Jo wouldn't be playing you know I
knew what happened to him um I was about
to sit again my ankle not 100% but I was
like man I'm not leaving my team out
there I got to go out there we got to
compete get one dub at least on this
road trip well number one tyres
congratulations on your first Allstar
Gall man it's well deserved but my
question is I hear you canceled your
golf tournament last summer cuz you were
ducking
me hey no no no no we going we going to
run it back this tourn uh this summer
for sure for sure for sure hey look I
got to get some practice in there first
well hey make that to wait wait deep
deep deep in the summer when it play off
but man congratulations and please tell
your mom I said hello we'll do we'll do
hey hey hey Chuck you know my dad name
is Tyrone and my name is tyres just
letting you know you you know your mom
go crazy when I call you Tyrone oh my
she loses her mind she loses her mind
thank you y'all be
safe oh no that's all right said it all
yeah yes he did his ankles hurting yeah
you know I I the only question I would
have asked him you know and really talk
about it's two things it's one of a
couple of them I've heard and known you
know the whole James Harden because of
James not being there but he also says
how James has instructed him while he
was there how to be that guy uh that he
is tonight getting 50 and a lot of
people say oh was just the opportunity
guy I was actually in Los Angeles while
he was there working out and and before
noon the guy had had three workouts yeah
and so for me the putting the work in
yeah literally 6:00 a.m. 10:00 a.m. and
noon third I saw him at noon it was his
third workout and this is a guy who now
gets his first allar so hard work gets
it
done